nous sommes au stade jean bouin l'antre
du stade français paris avec le
versailles et les au bar et bonjour les
bons jours alors du coup un bon début de
saison puisque je rappelle un tué
arrière polyvalent au stade français
paris tu à 19 ans tu as joué neuf
matches depuis le début de cette saison
au sur 12 quel bilan tu fais de ce début
de saison du coup bah du coup plutôt
positif beaucoup de confiance aussi
personnelles données par le staff à un
début de saison un peu compliqué pour
nos supporters parce que on a pas on est
pas mal de défaites et abc dont beaucoup
plus positif pour moi pour ce début de
saison où j'ai pu enchaîner avec les
pros ouais t'as joué énormément de
minutes finalement deux joueurs c'est ça
a énormément de minutes de jeu puis
surtout une continuité cercle j'ai
réussi à enchaîner cinq matches
d'affilée à chaque fois après ils m'ont
laissé au repos 24 et c'était plutôt
c'était plutôt intéressant pour moi
d'évoluer avec les bras on va revenir
sur deux faits de jeu le premier d'abord
à perpignan une pénalité décisive pour
cette victoire à aimé giral dans oui
c'est ça fait très plaisir cette
pénalité c'est sûr beaucoup de fierté de
de la mettre surtout pour ce club
pour qui je veux enfin sa plus forte
dans le coeur et oui surtout fait ce
moment là c'est je viens de prendre un
coup et je me retourne directement vers
grenoble dire non je peux la prendre je
peux l'apprendre lui je pense qu'il
n'est pas trop chaud pour que je la
prenne et au final c'est plutôt bien
passé et puis voilà je rappelle que tu
as dix neuf ans comment gères justement
ce genre de situation où la pression
doit être énorme quand même je pense ont
la pression sur le banc le match on l'a
enfin moi les évacuer on joue on joue le
jeu c'est on joue au rugby voilà elle
parle dans une autre bulle au civ
je sais que après quand j'ai regardé le
match et beaucoup d'ambiance mais à aimé
giral mes matches et on est dans notre
bulle donc ça ça a beaucoup joué
moi parce qu'en tant que buteur faut
vraiment se mettre dans sa bulle l'autre
fait de jeu c'est un match face à
clermont pareil vous êtes devant et là
les clermontois vont pour inscrire un
essai et finalement dernier défenseur tu
arrives tu arrives à retenir et ne pas
faire que clairement mark cet essai qui
aurait pu les faire mangani quoi surtout
qu'il n'a pas contrôlé à bâle avant
qu'il n'apprenne c'est pas moi qui les
trois je vais un peu gêné mais je pense
que voilà
là sur ce match là c'est plutôt faut
plutôt noté pas cette action mais plus
l'équipe où on a fait un gros gros match
mais mais voilà oui pareil ça m'a fait
plaisir de rentrer guillemets sauver
l'équipe mais en soit je pense qu'il ya
vraiment fait tomber la banque us le
plaque alors je disais au début tu as
arrière polyvalent tu joues à la fois
demi d'ouverture centre arrière comment
tu gères tout ça justement cette
polyvalence je la gère enfin de façon
plutôt positif parce que c'est que du
bonus pour moi c'est que du plus de
pouvoir toucher à plusieurs postes
d'être 15 d'être 12 d'être dise voilà
c'est c'est vraiment top en plus ils me
font vraiment confiance le stade sur
chacun des postes donc c'est vraiment
une plus value pour moi et pour fort
surtout les années à venir me voir
plusieurs postes en poche c'est plutôt
bien on le connaît sur les antennes de
télé 78 vient de versailles est-ce que
tu déjà à versailles au rcv au
rugby-club de versailles tu tu avais
cette polyvalence cela en juniors en
cadets alors c'était un massif vosgien
quand j'étais à verser c'était à l'école
de rugby on n'a pas trop de poste
j'étais plus destiné à jouer à jouer dix
ou douze et puis après on a six as et
continuer son enfance à continuer avec
les deux postes et puis voilà c'est ça
continuer sur les années à massy puis
maintenant ce français alors au stade
français et y est depuis un an
maintenant tu as signant l est et 2020
tu nous disais l'année dernière quand on
était venu te voir que c'était le club
de ton coeur un an après ça va renforcer
l'attachement à ce club oui il a été
rattaché déjà comme j'avais les nerfs
c'est un club qui est assez historique
un parcours assez atypique par rapport
aux autres clubs et
et puis c'est surtout le club de la
capitale enfin voilà c'est ça a été
toujours j'ai grandi dans la région
parisienne donc le stade français pour
moi c'est un gros club et ça restera
hétu a prolongé son contrat en octobre
dernier jusqu'en 2025 et c'était un
choix parce que à cause de cet
attachement est achement et puis surtout
si le projet projets qui m'intéressent
beaucoup de faire jouer je pense le
maximum de jeunes de les imprégner
surtout de c'est surtout des jeunes qui
sont issus de la formation de la
formation parisienne en fin de matinée
ou des alentours je pense là à leicester
et tient joie des le bouillet ou même
ses cookies un peu plus vieux voilà
c'est des joueurs qui sont passés par
par la région ile-de-france et du coup
c'est le projet aussi du club que ce
soit qui ait un lien avec l'île de
france enfin la région ile-de-france
pour c'est pour ça aussi qu'il ya un
partenariat avec avec massy alors ton
engagement et pour le stade français
mais ton engagement il est aussi pour
l'équipe de france l'équipe de france
moins de 20 ans quels sont tes objectifs
justement avec l'équipe de france moins
de 20 ans sachant que tu as quatre
sélections déjà avec cette équipe ouais
c'est sa 4e sélection lerner au mois
deux mois de juin pour le ton à
destination les objectifs sont clairs
c'est déjà de participer et puis après
le gagner voilà c'est de gagner la
dernière on était on avait perdu contre
les anglais en entrée de tournoi où ça
nous avait un peu bousculé et on avait
super bien réagi ensuite
contre l'italie un peu timidement mais
surtout contre le pays de galles
l'écossé ensuite l'irlande mais voilà je
pense que cette année c'est une nouvelle
année avec des nouveaux joueurs et il
faut je pense aller chercher chercher ce
tournoi est aussi bon là je crois que la
coupe du monde est annulé mais il ya des
espèces de tournoi à la fin de la fin du
mois de juin donc faire de plus de
sections possible et clément de vin et
gagner plus possible quand tu vois les
grands le quinze de france les résultats
tu as déjà le quinze de france en tête
même si tu as encore 19 ans c'est encore
trop je pense encore trop jeune pour y
penser oui c'est sûr ça rêve pour chaque
joueur qui joue sur le terrain mais
vraiment là mon objectif il est déjà
joué avec l'équipe première du stade
maximum et
et participez avec les moins de 20 ans
mais c'est surtout vrai quand on voit
les résultats en équipe de france leur
dernière victoire face aux all blacks
c'est assez incroyable et c'est aussi
grâce je pense la formation qui acquit à
qui a dans tous les clubs de top 14 donc
ouais faut c'est dans le camp de la tête
mais pour l'instant on vise on vise plus
haut - moins de 20 à temps et la pluie
qui première un dernier mot les eaux
qu'est-ce qu'on peut te souhaiter pour
l'année 2022 ben maximum de matches en
pro et puis gagner surtout gagner puis
la santé surtout la santé merci de
léopard et arrière polyvalent du stade
français paris issue de la formation
versaillaise